All right.
We got one advertisement here and of course I'm reading this advertisement.
Well after I did the whole fucking interview with the wonderful Adler family,
um,
I'm in San Jose right now.
Ah,
but oh,
boat boat me undies,
me undies.
San Jose,
California.
Yeah.
Gudo Poo pooed me undies.
Me undies.
You won't get a hernia because those things will hold your balls nice and tight
against your tank to put them on.
It'll feel like velvet.
You won't need to get a hand job because your underwear is like a fuck and hot
chicks hand.
That's fucking gross.
Sorry.
Whatever.
Me undies,
everybody.
If you want to elevate your underwear,
if you want to elevate your underwear game to the next level,
I mean,
what level are you at?
You got shit stains in your drawers.
I don't know where the fuck you right.
You can elevate it with me undies and the fucking screen just stopped.
Didn't stop.
Now I got a pump type in my fucking password.
This is just not the way to do this.
Uh,
you've perfected your wardrobe,
but what about the stuff?
Not everybody gets to see.
If you've been settling for store,
bought underwear,
five packs.
I have something that will change your life for the better fucking me undies.
What's the first thing you put on and take?
It was the first thing you put on and the last thing you take off.
I don't want to know.
I don't want to know you like that.
All right.
Fucking keep your own God damn taken off and putting on a close to yourself.
All right,
you oversharing con millennial.
Uh,
it's your underwear.
Make your most important piece of clothing the best it can be with me undies.
What is me undies?
It's fucking underwear.
If you haven't figured it out,
it's just seriously soft.
Feel good undies delivered right to your door by some fucking weird of going.
A man wants to go around delivering sof fucking feeling underwear.
Look at that other guy in the eye.
Here you go.
Uh,
me undies had signed in La and made from sustainable source,
micro modal,
modal,
a fabric three times softer than cotton.
Beyond these softer than soft luxury underwear come in an ever changing
selection of classic colors,
bold shades that you can put on your balls and it'll be a safe place for your
nuts.
Um,
and guess what?
You can save time and money each month with us monthly subscription.
And if you're not ready to first subscription,
that's no problem.
That's no fucking problem.
You can still save us because [inaudible] is offering 20% off your first pair.
Just use my special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr and get 20% off your first pair.
Uh,
so go ahead.
Revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it.
Once again,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash burr be undies.com/now back to the Steven Adler
interview.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's build bird is time for a very special Monday morning podcasts.
Every once in a while I have this special ones.
It's not me just in my jam jams running my Yap and my old piece of Shit House
that has a lot of character.
Uh,
speaking a characters.
We got some characters in here today.
Uh,
we have selling her new book here.
That's out.
Uh,
Steven Adler Drummer,
a rockstar.
Extraordinary.
Her new book called Reading Sweet Child of mine because I don't want to make,
I don't want to show your phone to make sure I don't screw this up.
No days.
Huh?
The end.
Sorry,
I didn't get him interrupted.
All right,
save an add.
Let's hear his brother.
Jamie's here.
Dan is here.
I feel like it went over that house for Thanksgiving.
They've come over here.
Then it's just going to be,
it's going to be a fun shelf.
This is going to remind me going home for the holidays,
so I'm sorry.
The enhancers.
Snoop books,
sweet child of mine,
which is basically her story of having,
it's a story of unconditional love between a mother and a son and not only that,
it's a story about it,
how many mistakes and mother can make in her relationship with his son.
And so I made a lot of mistakes.
I got him off.
Where would be like,
why?
This is the first time I've ever heard of myth.
It's true.
Oh God.
This is becoming like doctor Phil here.
You guys.
Yeah,
it was bring some tissues over here in a minute.
He did.
Um,
Branton dead.
I actually,
I uh,
you know,
I got,
believe it or not in my podcast,
listeners know I'm a terrible reader.
I can't read out loud.
I'm really bad and I just got the book yesterday.
I count sing so it's okay.
There you go.
So I got all the way up to like I got up to about page 75 of the book and it's
incredible.
Just what I mean I keep,
you know,
I can't wait until for the next hundred months stand.
I'm stopping.
That's just as far as I got.
Cause I read slow but good to things like your,
your day at go the first mom.
His Steven.
All right.
Do you slapped?
But it was in the arm though.
That's a misdemeanor.
It goes through the hand,
the arm,
the shoulder to phase the head where you weigh.
Uh,
we,
cause my mother hit us when we were kids.
I mean it was just,
you spanked and then you moved up to the paddle wooden spoon to you.
One of those wouldn't spine all of the wooden spoon.
All right.
Let me ask you this Steven,
your,
your preference as a child,
was that the wooden spoon be random blunt object.
Yeah,
we get the hairbrush.
I got that.
I was a hairbrush a couple of times,
of course to random object thrown through the air.
They had definitely say see you,
your vault and you got to have beautiful healthy.
You look really good.
You're very answered that me,
my head is lumpy and you did the Bosley.
I don't have a good ball head.
So that's the thing is you're going fall,
you're praying,
you're like,
oh you went to Fox with that.
I'm going to Bosley do a lot of rock rockstar.
They've got it.
Cause the only movie stars Rock Stars,
it's a 21st no,
it just kill me if can do it.
Do it.
The amount of bands where there'll be five people in the band and I'll be
watching it at home as a ball gag and there's no fucking way one of these guys
didn't go.
There's no way
less of all miles.
I have that disease.
You know.
It's where I'm losing my hair.
It's called middle aged and it's going to happen to everybody out there.
I just came into it
and I still look good for an old bag.
You know it's about your book.
Not only do you get dealt,
the unbelievable unconditional love that you have for your whole family is,
it really made me want to go get some Italian food cause it was so much of it
talking about it.
I'm actually going to make meatballs tonight.
When you were talking about when early on for people who haven't read the book
yet.
Um,
Steven spawn,
Deanna used to come by there,
their apartment used to bring them food and everything when they were struggling
and they have more buyers studios.
He was on brace for cause he's a great cook.
My mom's a fabulous cause you know,
makes up putting it in Tupperware and bring it down.
Grab our laundry,
go just watching the table.
Cause that's kind of like a lot of noise.
I'm just letting you know all cause after everything just all hitting the table,
God can kick.
Not trying to put some restrictions on you.
I just want people to hear what he is a drummer bill.
He is a drummer.
I got ready to go with the arms of the chair are here.
What is your,
uh,
what's your go to dish?
Uh,
you want to impress people that come and buy eggplant permission and make a very
good eggplant Parmigiana and make a very good lesson.
Yeah,
I make it very good sauce.
I'm a good cook.
I'm not bragging.
Right.
But when you're good,
you're good.
I,
it's a big part of the book though.
So that must've been,
so when you went over there,
you got early on,
you got a sense that the band was going to,
was going to take off.
Oh No.
Nothing like that.
Or our studio,
our bathroom,
Damon work.
And it was,
she just didn't even go in CSI,
I don't know,
10 minutes talking about the studio,
the studio behind Guitar Center that we are used to live at.
Well,
we lived at girls' houses,
but that was her like a rehearsal.
And we always hang that and she,
you know,
would come buy from it as food.
I never understood how they did that.
Try and make it as a comedian,
you're just by yourself and as bad as it is,
you're sorta this little dictator and you can decide when you're going to eat
and blah blah blah blah blah.
But if you're in a band,
you know there's always going to be the late guy,
the other guy doing this,
like I don't know how you going.
I said I always love being part of a team.
Like when I was younger I played football.
I loved the way to when you get together and everybody creates something
together,
right.
Let me just see.
My Dad had the time.
We created such great magic and it just happened.
Have you read your mom's book?
No.
I'm afraid to read it cause I already know.
I already can imagine what the pain I put her through.
If I read it.
That's what you get in this book because I Read Your Book and you know I'm
rooting for you the whole way through.
Obviously a huge fan of everything.
But now to get the other side of a lot of those stories,
you know the worry that,
uh,
I got to tell you,
dude,
I'm not gonna lie.
You put it through hell man,
only really put it through health.
I mean,
I didn't wake up every morning real hell and don't forget that h e double hockey
staves,
l l I s denied.
You know,
I didn't wake up in the morning and go,
hey,
how can I,
you know,
my mother and her and my family and my friends.
No,
I had to,
it was,
I was,
you know,
I'm an addict so I did what I did and think about it,
the constant,
I just became a dead two months ago.
So now I'm reading this from a,
from an extra couple of months.
Yeah.
So I'm reading it from a new perspective and I call,
I can be on both sides rather than being the messed up kid,
which I already did that.
Now seeing.
So,
um,
if you want to tell people like,
cause you touched on part of the book,
like those,
those feelings when you were,
you're sitting at home.
I mean you're always going to remember him as a little baby and you know,
he's out on the street and everything.
That must've,
you know,
ditching school.
Let me just,
let me get real quick.
Wow.
I track going,
hi.
I'm really starting to see this dynamic.
Yeah.
When he was growing up,
I didn't worry about it because I knew where he was.
He was back grandma's house.
But then I,
okay,
there's a mistake right there.
I knew he was at grandma's house,
but I didn't know what was going on when he was living at Grandma's house.
They wouldn't be going out on night and going to these clubs and uh,
but I didn't worry about it cause I thought,
okay,
he's safe.
He's at Grandma's house.
And what happened when you found out that,
that he wasn't there?
Well,
I didn't find out until years later how old I was.
I did school everyday.
You know,
they never did the school never even called her.
Yeah.
This was like the 70 [inaudible] going to a liquor store at 15 and you're kind
of a pack of cigarettes and I'm buying a six pack of beer and drink old enough.
Yeah.
Drinking Age was 18 right?
It was 21.
Oh,
what's 21?
I mean Sasha will just walk in somewhere and just give me some cigarettes were
taking his beer and it was not a seventies were gray man.
Ray Lewis,
Allen,
I'm telling you I want to tell a story.
Okay.
Okay,
I got you.
You're still going to keep the tension down guys.
Um,
so what um,
do you have any like uh,
do you have any like,
cause I haven't got that far into the book.
Do you,
do you end up giving advice because I think this will be an incredible book for
parents that there were dealing with the situation that you were dealing with.
I could never give advice to anyone.
I'm not a doctor.
I'm not a professional person and not a psychiatrist or anything like that.
I'm just even apolis mother and I told about what it,
how it affected me,
the things that he did.
But if I wanted to tell people what to do,
if I want to do that,
I would say if you have a son or daughter that's an alcoholic or drug addict,
take care of yourself.
And that took me a long to learn.
I mean,
years to learn this was stop worrying about him.
That's his life.
You didn't teach him to drink or take drugs,
you didn't do that to him,
right?
Oh No,
I didn't do that to him.
Was around their kids.
I don't,
I don't know anything about that.
You know about drugs or alcohol.
I didn't,
I didn't know what was going on and um,
but I would tell people to go to Al Anon meetings,
go to Aa meetings to take care of yourself.
Don't worry.
Try to understand what you're dealing with and exactly right.
So you know what your friend or your,
you know,
your associated or whoever your son or daughter is going through what they're
thinking and you go to the Allen on me,
then you realize you're not the only one.
And he just feels so much better in our meetings.
Was that,
that was your experience?
Well,
what happened?
But it was my daughter in law,
Carolina,
Steven's wife,
she would tell me,
go to an Al Anon meeting,
go to an Al Anon meeting.
And I say,
no,
I don't want to go there because I don't want to hear anybody else's problems.
Okay.
But finally I went to my first Al Anon meeting,
which was a few years ago.
And I walked in there and I w I thought to myself,
do they know who I am?
I'm so ashamed.
You know,
my son's a drug addict as an alcoholic.
Do they know who I am?
Well,
you know,
when you go to these meetings,
when you introduce yourself,
you only say the first name so they don't really know who you are.
And,
um,
and I listened to what everybody is saying and you want to know,
say,
I walked out of there and I said to myself,
oh my God,
I don't have it so bad.
There was such stories to be told.
People have it so much worse than me.
I couldn't believe it.
And I felt good about myself.
Did that make you go two more or three more?
Yes,
yes.
I go to more.
Yes.
I've gone to Aa meetings to listen to what these drug addicts have gone through
their stories.
It doesn't hurt me to do this.
And then when I go to the knowledge is important.
I uh,
I got arrested for drinking and driving and like the uh,
the late eighties,
and one of the things that you had to go to like a couple of AA meetings and I
was concerned like,
Oh God,
what is this going to be like?
And I went there and that actually did make me feel better.
I was like,
all right,
I drank.
I don't not do want these people that do.
Yeah.
I always feel better going there.
I was forced to go when I got arrested and I celebrity rehab.
So I love that I got arrested on a show about doing drugs because I had drugs on
me.
I hours my highlight of my blog,
I was a highlight.
Okay.
But so I was Kinda,
I was,
I had to go for three months every day I had to get this paper signed and I'm so
glad I did.
I had to go and then like after the first couple of days I enjoyed it.
I go,
it was one hour a day.
Did you look great?
And thank you.
You look great.
I got to over three years.
Yeah,
you,
oh you look,
you look,
you know they ain't clear ride and everything.
He'll be going to the gym every morning.
We have now we have a life.
This is a weird day.
Know that,
I mean me,
comedians have joked about this something,
if you do hard drugs in your 20s you have like abs for life.
You guys are all in like crazy shape.
Nobody else.
Every,
I gained
40 pounds when I was drinking as the last three years before I got sober three
years ago,
uh,
I was drinking egg or my sir.
And you want to know something,
you could drink it.
What age did it,
I said,
well,
I wasn't drinking.
You know,
when I was younger I had a few beers.
You go to the rainbow and you know,
get the long island ice teas that go in and use the buyers.
And,
but it wasn't like I went to the liquor store every day,
but before I got sober three years ago,
every morning I've drank from six o'clock when the liquor store open,
I would be there sometimes before the owner got dare open up.
Oh Hey.
It seem it.
How's it going?
How do you think it's going?
I'm at the liquor store fucking before you.
I listen.
Goshawks going,
wait a minute.
I want to say something
nice on tries.
He was so skinny.
Like,
oh,
like a weed.
So turning to heroin and crack.
We'll do that too.
Oh yeah.
So live on God Taco bar or a Jack in the box tacos and Ding dongs and Hagar my
sir.
That's,
that's the life of a,
of a store guy to me.
You know,
I've listened to you and this new 52 years,
I'm so tired of this.
They'll list the silence.
Okay.
Silence is golden liquid
queen.
Why let the Queen Speech?
I hear the love.
I still hear the,
I just want to finish this out.
Okay.
When he,
when he was drinking alcohol,
he was heavy and I would tell everybody,
oh,
Steven never looked so good.
He's got some fat on him now.
He's not so skinny.
He's shit to look at them.
I didn't know that.
That's what alcohol does.
An alcoholic because of all the sugar.
It's an alcohol and it was a sweetheart.
You're making meals for people.
You're encouraging and all that.
I get the,
you know,
so you're not looking for unusual and wonderful by that.
I just,
you know,
made you food kitchen with the brush.
Sorry.
Get it straight and woods.
My grandmother probably wouldn't spoon over.
She tried to hit me in the head with it and they got the arm up the block and
you've been,
he broke,
he broke it on your grant and then she immediately,
she snapped out.
She had this crazy liquid.
She went to hit me in the second it's snapped.
She just went,
she just went back to normal calls.
He had to do was just get a solid hit anywhere on you.
She felt better.
I really tell them Max,
my kid story about Jamie,
I used to,
I used to hit him with the winds,
but just on the thigh,
nothing terrible.
Nothing terrible.
Acceptable.
So one night he talked back to me.
So either I,
I used to wash out their mouth,
but so now we teach you really do it,
make them stick the bar in there to wash face time.
I couldn't,
you know,
I was too little to do anything about it.
She's got to take a water break here.
Hang on a second.
Little soda pop
with Jamie,
my youngest son,
he sassed me back.
So I,
I didn't have the cell bike,
I didn't get the soap,
so I had the wooden spoon.
So I started chasing him around the dining room table.
I said,
I'm going to get you,
you're not going to talk like that to me.
I won't have it.
10 years old at the time.
Yeah.
So you're agile,
you're low to the ground,
you've got a low center of gravity.
So I got so mad at him.
I threw the wooden spoon at Jamie.
He grabbed the wooden spoon and start chasing
is never going to happen again.
When we
have now,
wait a minute,
he can't have that running after me with the wooden spoon and we've started to
laugh and laugh and that was the end of the window was it?
I took them,
put under my bed and it was done.
When I did my,
my dad was in a fraternity and he kept a paddle as a souvenir.
My mother used to hit us with it,
so I took it and I hit it.
I hit it in between their mattress because I figured they would never look
there.
They would rip it apart out rooms.
Trying to find a hat writes,
you know,
Jesus.
Even as a kid,
I was out of necessity.
Those was,
my mother didn't have the greatest aim.
We're streetwise.
No,
I was Culdesac wise.
I wouldn't hit him on the thigh or the tuition.
That's all.
Nothing.
My Mother didn't have good hand eye coordination or she gets so mad she'd miss
and she'd hit your lower back or the bottom
by accident.
I'm not trying to indict.
I think the statute of limitations ran out at this point.
Yeah,
he's worn out,
but at times is so different.
You know?
Tell me here,
parent gives,
their kid is back on her toes or something and it was like,
oh,
you're going to jail and volunteer because this kid for 24 hours a day like I
do,
you would smack him.
It's what it is.
But there wasn't,
there wasn't all these video cameras.
You know,
I just realized,
I didn't even say where you can get your book yet.
Your book is available@amazon.com once a time.
Once upon it.
Once again,
I can't thank
fileable not book smart.
Hey,
can I out?
I'm all mixed up and amazon.com it's a noble Adler's book,
sweet child of mine.
It's available@amazon.com there we go.
I mean,
go ahead.
Oh,
you're talking about
you're inviting bill book signing March 29th at Barnes and noble.
I'll be over in the grove.
I think
I'll definitely swing by.
Jamie will be there.
My brother,
I'll do a lot of celebrities.
My brothers having all his friends come out.
I had three friends in my life.
I have three.
Broke it down to three.
That's all you need.
It's all is.
Yeah.
I got two pairs of Pants,
seven shirts,
12 pairs of socks at 12 years old.
I knew.
Or did you get the,
uh,
the world travel,
like luggage packing thing down?
We're like,
oh yeah,
this is Barry.
It you just made like the size of a breadbox.
What would you,
when you're,
you're going to do a world tour.
You were leaving your apartment for a year.
What are you bringing two pairs of pants by?
Pj's a pair of sweats,
a tee shirts.
I knew her sobs,
I let me tell him know.
Sure.
So what I said,
I want to tell you a story about him going on tour.
Come up closer to the mic a little bit.
One day he calls me up and he's deaf.
This,
uh,
um,
Kotel and he said,
Ma,
you come on by here.
I got some clothes.
I've got some things I want you to take home with you.
We're going to play down in 10 in England.
And I said,
okay.
So,
um,
I go to the hotel and he comes out of the hotel and he's wearing pants that are
slipped.
You know how that in the 80s,
they had the holey jeans they were feeling.
And also not only that,
there were splits by his Tush.
Okay.
By the tuition.
He's a rock star.
We didn't worry.
I knew her back then.
Any right
now,
no idea.
Wait a minute.
I say to them,
this,
stop,
tell this story.
No.
And so now he's coming on and I see he's wearing these torn pants.
I said,
Steven,
I says,
you can't go on the Concorde like that.
you have to dress properly.
He says,
don't worry my,
it's okay.
It's all right.
So a few minutes later,
we're talking in a few minutes later,
a great,
I'll never forget it.
A great big gray stretch limousine pulls up to the front of the hotel and he
says,
oh,
that's my ride.
I says,
okay.
So he walks down to the car and the guy opens the door for him to get into
limousine and he turns around and looks at me,
says,
see my,
it's okay.
What I'm wearing,
what I wearing know what does that like as a mother to have
achieve like that I very proud of Steven.
He's accomplished so much in his life and I'm sure we've gone through a lot of
bad times,
but that's over with now and I'm very happy,
you know,
we're,
we're waiting.
We walk out his studio.
You're so done.
Wait,
I'm going to age you.
10 years went to walk out of here.
If I wanted to hear any of your shit.
I squeeze your head thing.
Oh,
here we go.
Here we go.
Well during that time,
what was,
what's your,
uh,
what's your favorite city to play?
The Amsterdam.
Amsterdam for the obvious
shit.
Damn.
That's what I'm looking for.
A new house,
you know,
everywhere.
But I had to say Argentina.
South America is the greatest place.
You know what's amazing?
ACDC is best live video I think is,
it's from somewhere in South America and the level crazy that the fans are gun
was embarrassing to me as a concert goer and like as a go concert go.
I thought like I thought I was bringing it for the band.
Like the whole place was going nuts place.
Even if people in the stands there are so passionate,
ever seen iron main concert when they went down there.
Oh Shit.
Watching iron man calms it down there and it's insanity.
It's just a whole,
you know,
River Plate stadium as a giant mosh pit.
What was that feeling the first time you played and you're sitting back there?
Cause that's the drummer,
you know,
you get to kind of sit down and take it in.
So you've got all you see is the greatest thing in my life is everything I ever
dreamed of and more.
How did you play that night?
Our grain just took it to the next level.
I salt.
Oh yeah,
no it's,
you know,
he started small and then work your way up because that's the dream is not as a
play for five or 10 people.
Oh,
if the plate for you know,
five or 1,000 thousand people,
what blew me away about your plane was,
you know,
I was a frustrated drummer before I became a comedian.
And back in the 80s,
I'm sure you remembered,
like everybody had these giant kits.
Even if they were just playing like a two four thing and then you came out,
you would just had a little four piece kit three.
It was actually pretty.
Anyway,
when we started,
it was just a base there and floor Tom ride crash and the Hyatt and the
Colville.
How did you like the look was even if you didn't play double bass,
a lot of people have that.
The second kick set up without even a pedal.
I had that look.
And then um,
I was playing with this other band and during the afternoon and I got a call
from slash saying that,
um,
we're going to do a doll.
Fucked up his show at the troubadour on Thursday.
And then he hooked up with a show I'll show in Seattle and in Oregon.
So I've said,
he said,
you want to go?
And I said,
well,
of course I want to go my bags packed my whole life,
which is approximately 2018,
19 years.
Okay.
So,
um,
I think we got to get back to your mind.
When I brought,
I was playing with his other band and I,
if was my mom's house Donthe analysis,
say,
Oh
hell.
But anyway,
I broke my bass storm has,
so when I went to Paris and I said,
I'm not going to set the whole thing up.
I'm just going to use the three pieces.
And it just worked out well,
I'll tell you,
you got,
you got more out of that.
Yeah,
guys got out of a tent down.
It's all I need.
That's the front of the Trump part.
Sorry mom.
Sorry.
Tell him about the first time I saw you play.
I'd love to hear that.
The first time that sounds playing,
I think it was at the Troubadour,
wasn't the trooper that had the troubadour.
The other ones,
it doesn't matter why.
I can't even
let me
talk for two minutes.
So sorry.
Out of his mind,
I'm getting the wooden spoon.
This is making me feel homesick.
This is exactly like calm.
They get back into the kitchen where you belonged with nice guys.
Jesus.
Anyway,
it's the first time I saw him play.
You were in that you are in the expressway to heaven,
one of the express lane.
They have been watching you dealing with this shit.
You still have an older one that ever even seen yet.
Sorry,
I interrupted.
Go ahead.
I'll let me,
sorry.
Anyways,
I saw,
I went to see him play and Jamie was with us and Jamie was I think about nine
years old and we got a call from Steven and Steven says,
coming to watch us play,
I since it's a school night,
we can't come.
He says,
come after dinner just for a little while.
So I said,
okay.
So we drove one to how we were living in the valley at the time and uh,
we drove into Hollywood and we parked the car down the street.
I remember this.
And all these boys and girls,
young young adults,
they had on black leather pants and the sheer blouses and,
and their hair was up to the ceiling and,
and makeup like you wouldn't believe.
And those were the guys
or the horn
worms.
So we went up to the front of the venue in and there was a security guy there
and he said,
I said to him,
my system,
can you please tell Steven Adler,
his mom and dad are here,
brother.
He says,
of course.
So Steven tells us to come into the,
Steven comes out and he tells us to come into the venue and he said,
no,
I want you to stay on the side of the,
on the side of the venue.
I said,
he said,
don't go in the middle.
It says,
go to the site where you're safe.
And I think to myself,
what?
He's to be safe,
what's going to go on here?
So a few minutes later the lights go out,
it's pitch black in the venue and all of us sudden Steven starts to play and
it's like a seven 47 landing on my head.
That's how loud it was.
Crazy.
So right away of course I got death,
you know,
I didn't hear nothing anymore.
That was the end of me.
I was deaf for about three or four hours.
You're deaf.
I said,
did I say deaf?
I said deaf.
And
about three or four hours I was deaf on the way home.
I couldn't hear anybody talk and it,
I said to myself,
oh my God,
I can't do this again.
It was too much for me.
So right away the next time I bought earplugs,
putting in my ears,
I didn't realize what was going to happen.
I didn't understand it because I had never done anything like this before.
Anyways,
we were very proud of him.
And um,
so the second time you've probably got to boys playing a little more cause you
weren't dealing with FAU for sonic.
Oh yeah,
it was.
She,
it was very,
very loud when they start to play.
My favorite,
sorry,
when they came to the shows,
they brought my grandmother.
Oh yeah,
35 year old grandma that wow.
I got to add a little Jewish leave about four three and then I said at the bar
here at the Troubadour,
I mean,
I was more safe though and you know,
and my mom and my grandmother standing there and actually no,
she looks down at my grandma's gone.
I'm playing.
I said,
and I'm looking around.
I looked down in the front row,
there is my grandmother,
she's standing right in front of his day.
That's my CV.
I love you.
Stevie and action was wearing a pair of chaps,
you know the d string,
red or gray hair,
the last grade that and my grandmother's right there.
Two feet away.
I'm going to get,
I live there,
get out,
I'm playing or go over there.
But my mother never saw,
looked at athletes.
She was just,
of course,
I'm the only one in that.
She had how many?
How many kids and grandkids?
30.
No,
she had 14 grandchildren.
Yeah.
But cares about
any of them.
But me has this,
uh,
last,
is this your longest stretch being sober?
Three years.
That's a month before I was 11.
Yeah.
First 11 years of your life you killed are killed it man.
Don't you wish those years counted?
Yeah.
You know what,
you don't go like,
what's the longest you've been sober?
Like I,
for me it was probably the first 15 years.
I just 15 years.
I had a good 11 years.
That's amazing.
This must be,
is this an easier time then?
Uh Oh Deanna for you now that now that he's,
you know,
look at them.
I can finally Christmases.
Look at him.
I could finally sleep at night because for 30 years,
every night when I went to sleep it was,
oh my God,
is this a corner going to call?
Is the hospital going to call the police?
I mean,
one mother could sleep when there's,
when the sun is out.
Right.
It was funny.
That's why I didn't do any of those chair.
I didn't do any Charlie sheen jokes because I just kept thinking when Charlie
Sheen was going off the rails and everyone's like laughing about the tiger blood
and all that stuff I just kept thinking about is,
you know,
cause you Emilio Estevez I grew up watching his movies and I love this almost
his dad.
So I was just thinking like this,
sitting by a phone waiting to get that phone call that he's dead.
So everybody's just sitting there watching that train wreck of a,
you know,
tore that.
He did.
I never saw the humor in it.
Well,
you know,
I also know,
I ain't said that didn't make it either.
So,
and the,
you know what,
there's a lot of parents out there who have lost their sons and daughters to
drugs and uh,
and they're just regular people,
but their hearts are broken now.
Yeah.
I,
I remember one story and I think I told this story before about this real estate
lady.
I was selling my condo in Las Vegas and a real estate lady came to my house and
uh,
she looks at and she comes in the house and she sees all these gold and platinum
records on the wall.
And then she says,
whose records are these?
Who's awards are these?
I said,
well,
they belonged to my son,
Steven Adler.
He's the original drummer from guns and roses.
And she said,
Oh my God,
your misses Adler.
And I says,
yes.
And she says,
can I come after I finished my client,
can I come back and talk with you?
I suppose,
of course.
So she comes back a little while later and we sit down in the living room and
she says,
I'm going to say something I haven't said in five years.
I says,
well,
what is it?
She says,
my daughter died of a drug overdose.
And I've never said that before.
I tell everyone that my daughter died in a car accident because she couldn't
bring herself
to say it because they plant themselves as like a shame.
Right,
right.
It's a shame and there's no need to be ashamed.
But it was a shame.
So I says,
she says,
I've never told anyone this until you,
she never said for five years or to,
she didn't tell her family or friends.
She just tells me,
Oh my daughter died in a car accident,
but it wasn't true.
So she was able to tell me because she knew that I would understand what she's
talking about
on porn to be able to tell somebody these things that you're holding inside.
Cause resentment is one on main worst things for an addict,
especially his wisdom and but refer anybody.
You have resentment.
You can't move forward with your life when it was it being able to talk about it
and get it out of your system.
That's the first thing that it's like,
I mean this is happening to many people.
I talked about in my book about when I was,
I was living at my grandma's house.
You know,
I was 12 1314 years old and I used to hang out at the Starwood.
Yup.
You know,
I lived up relived off here of facts in Santa Monica.
Hayworth in Santa Monica,
so you know,
it's west Hollywood.
So you know,
I,
there's always guys trying to pick you rob.
It was the 70s and I used to hang out at the rainbow and that,
and uh,
it's uh,
the star wood and stuff like that and one,
I get this,
all their teenager,
I was saying with drug me and I ended up getting a sexually abused by these,
by these two guys and I was like 13 years old and I couldn't talk about that for
each forever.
But if something that was deep insights Berkeley that wasn't accepted for
anybody for the longest time,
forget about it.
As a guy.
Yeah.
Some of the,
they almost like I was 13 I don't think you can.
Yeah.
Keeping any shifts with that,
but you know,
the dad dies.
But I,
I,
once I talked about that in my book and I mentioned you doing when you wouldn't
believe how many people have come up to me and says you talking about that made
me be able to talk about it.
I'm not telling them,
one,
two,
three,
I traveled around the world.
Okay.
You guys,
you guys are pulled looking at both to them.
Great.
Do you guys have to hit,
we're survivors.
Do you guys think you're going to have a,
you know,
now that you're sober and everything you could,
maybe you guys will have a third book and you,
you know,
well you don't have to hit him with the spoon.
He still going to be hitting me with the stones in a bed.
I'm going to be hitting her and with US foreign,
it's not heard.
Me and Meagan,
I don't have anything left in me after this
reads that way though.
I mean you're really put it out there.
So I got it.
I told the truth about everything.
See,
I've been writing this book says since 1984 every time I was see him perform or
we went through this,
literally writing it,
yes,
I would write down notes on a piece of papers saying,
well this is what happened today.
And,
and um,
she's good though.
She's just one of those people who've rights has very nice handwriting and
enjoys writing.
I'm like,
I can't even read my signature is like,
what does it say?
Suit.
And I was in the game
so I never thought about writing a book.
But then a few years ago,
um,
Jamie said to me,
Ma,
you have all these pieces of paper,
all these stories,
why don't you put it together for a book?
And I said,
I never thought about that.
And so he got Larry Spagnola who is my co writer,
he put it all together for me.
It helps Steven.
He was helping Stephen,
he's,
he helps even with his book.
And so we call Larry and Larry says,
of course I'll help you.
You know.
So he helped me a lot and
I can't say enough.
My fans,
they know I don't read.
And if I get up my hands on a book and I can't put it down,
that's basically the way it is.
Um,
with this one.
So,
uh,
Jamie,
when are you going to write a book?
Man?
You're like the only guy left in the family,
right?
I'm working on my own book right now.
Don't peak at 25.
Okay,
Bill.
It's crazy.
Cause I've had at least like four or five phone calls from people calling me up
saying,
I had no idea your family was fucked up and mine is even worse than yours.
And he got sick.
It's unreal.
Like people are really calling me up saying,
I have a secret to tell you.
And like people are like really starting to divulge your secrets and every
family has one.
And my mom's book,
I really want this book to be a big success,
not because of,
well yeah sure I want to make some money,
but I want to be able to help the rest of the world.
I want the rest of the world to not have to hold on these secrets anymore
because like my brother just shared a crazy secret,
oh yeah,
eight years.
But he wrote his book in his book.
The guy admitted that he was such a blind read his book.
I remember that.
I was like,
so as soon as he said that it's within the next couple of years,
he kind of stopped doing heroin and crack.
Well because that secret that he was holding inside,
he was able to have that go.
And that's what they talked about.
When you carry mud,
you carry dirt like you're carrying a big load.
So all of a sudden my mom puts out this book that I've been getting some phone
calls from,
some pretty prestigious people that I looked up to,
and they're,
they're admitting that they have drug addicts and disease and their pride and
their family as well.
Now,
you know what I found with my comedy that there's a lot of angry people out
there.
However that is,
I've been working through my anger.
I have a portion of my fans going like,
dude,
you're not as angry.
Like they're getting mad at me cause I'm along.
You ain't a little happier.
We want you angry,
man.
I still love you.
Ain't stay angry,
dude.
What was it worth it not,
uh,
misery loves company x.
They want you angry.
Great disguise.
It is don't your edge.
It's like,
no.
What is my edge yelling at other people's mothers at a red light.
You know what I mean?
That's somebody's grandmother.
What am I doing?
I,
there's some point speaking for millions of people,
I have to bring it down a little bit,
you know what I mean?
So whatever,
there's always a couple people going to give you a rough time.
So,
um,
all right,
so we,
we got a little more time left.
Is there anything else?
Uh,
you know,
I mean,
what was it,
I'm sure it's in the book,
but what was the watershed moment where you finally saw your son have like this
breakthrough where you felt like,
okay,
like he'll actually like this time it might take like the,
he's gone on to three.
I run.
That's incredible.
Yes.
I,
I really never had that,
like you say,
watershed moment.
I just,
I've always always said to myself,
okay,
everything's gonna be all right.
The best is yet to come.
He's going to be fine,
you know?
But no,
it's been like a 30 year battle up and down roller coaster.
And it's just like,
we always have hope.
I mean,
we're the only two people that have never left Steven's life.
We've always been by his side.
All.
My wife's been with me 16 years,
well his wife and she never did a drug,
but we've been,
we've been together as a family this whole time.
The other,
there might be times we don't talk for like a year or whatever,
but we're always there for each other.
The craziest thing you guys ever tried to get him so because I would literally
at some point the love for my brother would be like,
I'm just going to chain this guy to a trait.
That's what I did.
I did that.
I did like go,
can't you see the tags?
The thing is you can't do that and then it doesn't work.
My friend Mark Cantor and forecast the La,
he wanted to chain me up.
There's radiator downstairs in his basement.
I said,
it's not going to work because as soon as I get out,
I don't want to have more reach that man and I don't want to go over the deep
end either.
He sat down and had a logical conversation like,
Steve,
listen,
I'm going to change at this rate.
Oh yeah,
mark,
can you hear me?
I'm going to change it to this rating.
Oh yeah,
it is book two with all the pictures that he took you guys down,
Margaret,
every Goddamn damn thing you guys have ever done.
Well,
family is wonderful.
I love long.
Yeah,
great.
I used to do so many crazy things.
I would nag him,
go to her.
We had do this,
do that.
It didn't do any,
I wouldn't go in,
but he had just the right keys down.
This is shut him up and I go and I ended up leaving the next morning and there's
35 $40,000 in the toilet because once you give them the money and you could
leave 10 you don't get that money back.
Rehabbed our biggest rip off.
Exactly.
Unless you're the owner,
it's the biggest rip off.
But if you're the owner,
you're,
you're making it back.
I call him revolving doors cause you're going to keep going in and out and in
and out.
And I planned on fastest recap.
You had like you went in the second,
the car drives away.
Do you walk right.
I didn't even get to it face my friend Bob Forest,
you know,
he works at Dr drew on,
he put me on a plane to go to I think Michigan or something like that and I got
on another plane and went to New York and his family too much.
So I went to some nightclubs and people recognize me and that's,
you know,
two to three weeks later I was on,
I'm going to,
I'm going to go back home and it's like I'm saying went back home,
never checked in to see if you win.
I'll call close it here,
but I didn't check in with them.
I just ever showed up.
Bill,
when your,
when your brother is your hero and you look up to him and he's this big rock
star in the guy's killing himself and you watch them die and kill himself for 30
years,
your last hope as he got to kidnap the guy,
the Los Angeles.
Right.
And that's what we ended up doing and it just made it worse.
It just made a completely worse and fast forward.
Fast forward years later,
the guy's alive and that's all that matters is words he at today.
Right.
Today he's alive and he's healthy and you know what,
he might have been dead or he might've still,
he's still alive.
Who knows?
But that's all that matters is the day you guys have any resentment for the shit
you went through with your brother?
No.
No I don't.
I don't have any resentment towards my room.
I'm sure he was a drug addict too.
I used to do drugs.
Of course.
I went to Rehab one time.
I've had my own share of experiences,
but the one that got me high the very first time when I was 12 years old was my
brother.
I wasn't day game,
but I was not driving.
But you know,
every everything had happened in life.
Happens for a reason.
It got me to where I'm at today.
And if my brother wasn't as big rocks or I wouldn't be the agent,
the manager that I am,
I wouldn't have this amazing lifestyle that I have.
But so resentments.
No,
of course I would have loved my brother not to been a Junky for 25 30 years,
but if I wanted to rock,
so John [inaudible] has to be a rockstar and movies though I be everyday
ordinary average guy.
Sure.
I pick up the dog do when it's your,
when it's your flesh and blood,
it's a little different.
Like you never give up on your flesh and blood and it's tall.
It's all talked about in that book and my brother's book too.
He has a chapter in there called thug love and I mean we could make a whole
movie on that one chapter,
giving them a milkshake and Las Vegas and he woke up in Los Angeles and then he
was held hostage for like three months.
I could have been going,
I could not go to prison.
I could've gone to prison for the rest of my life and they all,
I committed so many felonies across the state lines,
kid happy,
overseeing all this crazy stuff.
But you know what?
I had no other choice.
I didn't know what else to do.
That's my last resort is to try to help my brother.
No.
And then you know it,
the best celebrity have after that.
Yeah.
But see,
I would've done so every we had anyways,
you know,
it happened.
If they didn't,
they didn't kidnap me.
I wouldn't have the resentment that I did have towards them towards it.
That made everything worse because they kidnap me.
I mean,
he wasn't there,
but the people that were holding me hostage here giving me better and more drugs
then I was doing on my own.
Okay.
If this doesn't make you want to read all of these damn books,
I,
yeah.
You have to have the word I want to say won't load
story here.
Okay.
Jamie calls me up.
He's in Los Angeles and Steven and I,
Las Vegas and Steven and Jamie calls me up and says,
Ring Steven to Los Angeles,
drive him to Los Angeles,
Isis for what?
And he says,
we're going to put them in a rehab.
I said,
okay.
So Steven and I get in the car,
I,
we're driving and we're driving to Los Angeles and he's every two minutes.
He's poking his head in the back seat.
And I,
I know he's smoking.
I think he spoke in weed,
but he's not,
he's smoking crack.
So every few minutes he would go and put his hand in the back of the seat,
you know?
No,
you're good man.
You're good.
And so,
and you're not aware that you see right now
smoking weed.
So I could say,
I say to him,
stop smoking the weed.
Stop it.
I'm driving the car.
I don't want you to smoke in the car.
I told you not to smoke.
And Lo and behold,
he of course,
he's not going to stop.
He's not going to listen to anything I say.
And we're about an hour out of Los Angeles.
And all of a sudden I didn't know where I was and I've driven this route a
hundred times or more.
And all of a sudden I says to Steve and I said,
I don't understand where are we?
Why are we here?
Don't get it.
I stopped the car and he and he's,
and he says,
don't worry isis.
I don't know how to get to Los Angeles.
I said,
what should I do?
He says,
ah,
don't worry my,
I'll guide you.
I said,
[inaudible] okay,
go straight ahead and we go on a freeway.
I was contacted.
I never sat next to somebody doing crack.
I had people doing it on my stoop when I lived in New York and I'd walk around
it,
but I wasn't in and a couple different high on crack,
Steve,
Hey,
I'm an ad or done.
I didn't want to do anything.
Oh No,
I didn't know
what,
uh,
what happened to me.
I couldn't understand it because I never,
I never got like that.
But all of a sudden my brain went dead.
I couldn't
literally,
and he's,
and believe me when I tell Ya,
he guided me to exactly where I wanted to go.
Even if he's on crack or cocaine or whatever the hell he wants you to get on the
10 you're all set.
You're going to want Florida to stay on this,
take it wherever you're going.
You know her everywhere you're going.
If I wasn't,
didn't have that,
the drug that would have been lost to like,
Oh,
let me give you a big head.
Okay,
now I know where to go.
Go.
Let's keep going.
We're Jewish family.
How many Jewish families could say a story like that?
There's actually a lot.
Okay.
We'll probably is,
there was a lot more,
but we don't know about that.
Don't know about,
I don't know.
Hopefully all the stuff that you guys are putting out there in your books,
we'll uh,
we'll have the same effect that you have when you talked about how you were
sexually abused and you were talking about how you dealing with the son.
That's,
that's battling addiction.
Um,
I got to tell you,
everybody listening out there,
the book is phenomenal.
It's called a sweet child of mine by Deanna Adler and you can get that on
amazon.com and if you want to read the other side of Steven going through it,
you can read his,
my appetite for destruction,
sex,
drugs and guns and roses.
Um,
that's also available on amazon.com.
I can't.
Thank you guys.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
Why wants to say something?
I want to say one thing.
You could also find it at Barnes and nobles.
Oh,
you could find it on kindle.
And if you're in a foreign country all around the world,
you can find it on book depository and please,
if you're in the neighborhood,
I'm March 29th at 7:00 PM go to the Grove and I'm going to have my first book
signing at Barnes and noble and I'm very excited about it and I'd love to meet
you.
Come on.
I can't top that any day.
You go do Yanni Adler.
Steven,
Jamie,
thank you guys
so much for coming.
Thank you for having us,
man.
No worries,
no worries.
And thank you guys for listening to these special edition of the Monday morning
podcast.
I'll talk to you guys again soon.
I don't know what we're going to put this up.
So yeah.